Qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Gérald Darmanin
qu'on vient d'entendre à Calais dans ce reportage hier,
et qui dit,
c'est 1 procès d'intention qu'il vous fait, euh.
Que vous avez intérêt au cas où,
euh, ce qu'il n'y ait pas de réponse, finalement,
on va pas se mentir, c'est vrai que si le gouvernement
rate son coup,
si il venait à y avoir 1 dissolution,
euh, ce serait probablement votre faveur derrière,
s'il y avait des élections législatives.
Non mais Gérald Darmanin dit tout et n'importe quoi.
Gérald Darmanin, c'est pertinemment,
et ça, et ça l'embête bien
que le Rassemblement National
agit pour l'intérêt du pays
et que jamais nous n'avons pris de position purement
idéologique, nous avons toujours pris des positions,
et bien dans le bien commun,
pour le bien commun en tout cas.
Euh, en l'occurrence, sur ce texte,
si l'on peut l'améliorer,
si l'on peut faire en sorte de supprimer
la régularisation
des travailleurs clandestins qui est prévu dans le
texte, que l'on va dire, ça c'est votre ligne rouge,
c'est 1 des lignes rouges évidemment.
en tout cas, c'est la ligne rouge principale.
Euh, rappelons 1 petit peu l'histoire
de de cette régularisation.
Le texte initial déposé par le gouvernement prévoyait
cette régularisation à travers l'article 3.
Cet article 3
qui avait été voté
par tout le monde en commission des lois du sinat,
y compris par les LR.
Ensuite, cet article 3 a été supprimé
en hémicycle du Sénat
et a finalement été. Transformé en article 4 bis,
à quelque chose près, c'est la même chose,
c'est la régularisation des travailleurs clandestins,
des personnes qui ne respectent pas les lois de la
République. Et donc on voudrait, euh.
Leur donner 1 prime,
finalement, 1 prime à la clandestinité.
Donc nous nous disons, ce n'est pas possible,
d'autant plus qu'il y a, rappelons le,
5.000.000 de français,
ils sont sans emploi
et donc on ne peut pas se permettre d'aller donner
comme ça du travail
euh à à à des travailleurs étrangers
et de régulariser des personnes qui, euh.
Enfreignent les hauts de la République. Vous êtes.